c'est pour toi la guerre d'exclusif avec
des droits de visite je veux pas je vais
pas empêché tomas devrait comment vous
vous sentez au quotidien en commun ça va
mieux tous les deux ça va s'arranger ok
mais il sait jamais rien ou bien on va
bien votre traitement
ça vous fait du bien oui beaucoup
oui vous en faites pas je m'appelle
claire moi c'est ici
qui était cette petite fille avec une
robe rose
la petite soeur de jérémy et tu sais à
quelle école elle va denton c'est clair
c'est ça bonjour bonjour vous cherchez
une maison c'est quelque chose de bien
se présente
vous pouvez garder thomas demain soir
serait dû à faire rien de très important
vous venez ici depuis longtemps
environ 10 ans
tatiana grosse toi moi
[Applaudissements]
elle a l'air plutôt sympa
vous êtes ami depuis combien de temps on
n'est pas amis les garçons jouent au
foot ensemble c'est tout tu ne trouves
pas qu'on se ressemble
si vous voulez je peux prendre les
enfants ce week-end je suis avec papa ce
week-end
j'ai perdu ma petite fille ya sept ans
pour me raconter ça
parce que plus je regarde le lap que je
suis convaincu que c'est ma fille
c'est du délire li zhi a été interné
pendant presque un an aucune loi
m'interdit de devenir une harcèle notre
famille un père
[Musique]
quant à la ligue
ne vous approchez plus de ma famille
il faudra me tuer parce que je lâcherai
jamais j'avais perdu la tête
[Musique]